mercredi soir réunion publique houleuse
autour du changement des rythmes
scolaires attrape dès la rentrée 2013 le
maire doit lever la séance devant les
oppositions d'enseignants et de parents
d'élèves dans le public
Othman Nasro on le retrouve dimanche sur
le marché du centre-ville il distribue
une pétition pour demander le report de
la réforme on va obtenir le report de
cette réforme c'est la seule issue
possible on peut pas appliquer une
réforme comme ça sans sans écouter les
enseignants et sans écouter les parents
d'élèves
Othman Nasro n'est pas parents d'élèves
mais il entend se faire connaître sur la
ville cette mobilisation est une
première pour lui ce jeune chef
d'entreprise de 25 ans est trappiste
depuis trois ans il a créé l'association
trap citoyen un collectif qui dit-il se
veut indépendant mais dans les esprits
il y a forcément les municipales qui se
profilent
c'est idiot de faire cette pétition pour
les municipales c'est vraiment pas la
séquence maintenant à partir du moment
où nous on est dans l'opposition à
Monsieur Malandain il est évident que
les municipales font partie de nos
perspectives
otman Nasro espère rapidement déposer en
mairie sa pétition l'association entend
prochainement présenté 10 propositions
concrètes pour l'école